[Música]
Estados Unidos anunció el despliegue de
1500 soldados suplementarios en su
frontera con México esto a pocos días de
que expire el controvertido título 42
que permitía la expulsión de migrantes
por motivos de salud pública Washington
teme un repunte en la llegada de
migrantes en su frontera Sur
en Texas fue arrestado el presunto
sospechoso de matar el pasado viernes a
cinco vecinos hondureños que se quejaron
del ruido que hacía al disparar su arma
en la calle durante la noche se cree que
el detenido es Francisco Oropeza un
hombre deportado de Estados Unidos en
cuatro ocasiones
al menos 80 arrestados y 10 policías
heridos en Paraguay durante protestas de
Seguidores del ex candidato paraguayo
cubas que quedó tercero en las
elecciones del domingo y que denuncian
un presunto fraude electoral entre tanto
el presidente electo Santiago Peña
anunció que buscará restablecer
relaciones con Venezuela
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos en Estados
Unidos el gobierno anunció el despliegue
de 1500 soldados suplementarios en su
frontera con México para hacer frente a
un posible repunte de la llegada de
migrantes a la frontera esta decisión
llega a pocos días del fin del
controvertido título 42 que permite el
rechazo inmediato de los migrantes que
intentan llegar a Estados Unidos
argumentando motivos de salud pública
Gabriel colchón nos cuenta más
teniendo un
posible la llegada de indocumentados
Estados Unidos reforzará de manera
temporal su pie de fuerza militar en su
frontera con México
1500 soldados adicionales llegarán a
partir de la semana próxima Para apoyar
a la patrulla fronteriza durante 90 días
estos 1.500 militares que procederán del
componente de servicio activo cubrirán
lagunas críticas de capacidad como la
detección y el seguimiento desde tierra
la introducción de datos y el apoyo a
los almacenes hasta que la protección de
aduana y fronteras pueda atender estas
necesidades mediante apoyo contratado
esta decisión llega a pocos días de la
expiración del controvertido título 42
el próximo 11 de mayo una medida
implementada durante la administración
de Donald Trump que permite la
deportación automática de los migrantes
que intentan cruzar la frontera
terrestre estadounidense argumentando
riesgos para la seguridad pública
consecuencia de la pandemia de Kobe 19
las autoridades estimen ahora un repunte
de las llegadas de migrantes a su
territorio por su parte el presidente
mexicano dijo que su gobierno respeta el
despliegue de los militares
estadounidenses en la frontera pues es
parte de sus facultades es un gobierno
este
independiente soberano ellos toman esas
decisiones y nosotros las respetamos
Estados Unidos hace frente a un flujo
migratorio inédito con más de 2,76
millones de indocumentados interceptados
en esta frontera en 2022 como parte de
la estrategia de Washington para frenar
la migración irregular y fomentar las
vías legales se anunció la apertura de
centros migratorios en Colombia y
Guatemala
nos vamos hasta el estado de Texas donde
fue detenido el hombre sospechoso de
matar el pasado viernes a cinco vecinos
que se quejaron del ruido que hacía al
disparar su arma durante la noche la
policía lo buscó durante cuatro días el
principal sospechoso había sido ya
anteriormente identificado como
Francisco Oropeza un hombre mexicano de
38 años que había sido anteriormente
deportado de Estados Unidos en cuatro
ocasiones según medios locales se cree
que oropesa es el hombre detenido a poco
más de 10 kilómetros de Cleveland Texas
nos vamos a Paraguay donde una jornada
de protestas dejó al menos 80 restos y
10 agentes de seguridad heridos Los
Seguidores del ex candidato paraguayo
cubas que quedó tercero en las
elecciones del domingo denuncian un
presunto fraude electoral la
Organización de Estados Americanos la
oea y observadores de la Unión Europea
indicaron que no tienen indicios de
acciones fraudulentas en el proceso
electoral paraguayo Valeria sacón
enviada especial de France 24 nos da más
información
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en Paraguay los simpatizantes de
paraguayo Cuba es el tercer colocado en
la disputa electoral protestan contra un
supuesto fraude electoral estamos en las
inmediaciones del tribunal superior de
justicia electoral Y esto es lo que nos
dicen los manifestantes
[Aplausos]
no nos sentimos identificados con el
narcotráfico viva el Paraguay soberano
[__]
[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo que queremos conseguir es una
elección limpia hace más de 80 años nos
encontramos en esta situación todos los
jóvenes que estamos aquí estamos Porque
necesitamos un verdadero cambio
cambiaron completamente las elecciones
nos vendieron
[Música]
en toda la región del tribunal superior
de justicia electoral hay mucha policía
para evitar enfrentamientos y problemas
hoy el jefe de la misión de observadores
electorales de la Unión Europea dijo que
descarta tajantemente que hubo un fraude
electoral habrá que ver si en los
próximos días siguen las protestas o si
los ánimos se apaciguan y justamente el
nuevo presidente electo del país
Santiago Peña anunció que su
administración buscará restablecer
relaciones con Venezuela Peña destacó
que reabriera la embajada paraguaya en
Caracas cerrada desde el año 2019 desde
la capital venezolana Daniela Zambrano
nos dan más detalles de este
restablecimiento de relaciones el
presidente Nicolás Maduro confirmó la
conversación telefónica que sostuvo con
el recién electo presidente de Paraguay
Santiago Peña el pasado 30 de abril tras
la cual los mandatarios manifestaron su
disposición de restablecer relaciones
diplomáticas a corto plazo
recordemos que el presidente paraguayo
Don Martínez rompió relaciones con
Venezuela en enero 2019 tras desconocer
las elecciones presidenciales por
considerarlas ilegítimas una postura que
asumieron cerca de 60 países que
reconocieron a Juan guaidó como
presidente interino de Venezuela sin
embargo vale la pena destacar que en
varias entrevistas concedidas a medios
de comunicación internacionales Santiago
Peña advertido que restablecer
relaciones con Venezuela no significa
que Paraguay no pueda hacer una voz
crítica que exija respeto a los Derechos
Humanos así como elecciones libres e
independientes y con garantías un punto
importante también en la relación entre
ambas naciones es la deuda que mantiene
la estatal petróleos paraguayos con la
petrolera pdvsa que asciende a unos 290
millones de dólares y por la cual en
2016 pdvsa solicitó un arbitraje ante la
cámara de comercio internacional con
sede en París
el informático
dado el padrino de la Inteligencia
artificial dio la última advertencia
sobre los peligros de esta tecnología
Hilton advierte tras abandonar su
trabajo en Google que impulsada por una
competencia no regulada esta tecnología
avanza demasiado rápido y amenaza la
verdad el empleo y la propia humanidad
La Casa Blanca anunció que el jueves la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris se reunirá
con los directores de Google Microsoft
Open ahí y alfabete entre otros
es una tecnología que podría ser
superior al cerebro humano y uno de sus
Pioneros dice ahora que una parte de
lamenta haber participado en su creación
Jeffrey Hilton informático de 75 años
dice que dejó su trabajo en Google Para
poder compartir de forma independiente
sus preocupaciones sobre la tecnología
de Inteligencia artificial que incluyen
temores sobre la desinformación y la
pérdida de puestos de trabajos humanos
pero que también va mucho más allá
qué hacemos para mitigar los riesgos a
largo plazo de que cosas más
inteligentes que nosotros tomen el
control cosas como el chipity Four
eclipsan a una persona en la cantidad de
conocimiento generales que posee y la
eclipsan con creces en términos de
razonamiento no es tan bueno pero ya
hace razonamiento simples y dado el
ritmo del Progreso Esperamos que las
cosas mejoren bastante rápido así que
tenemos que preocuparnos por eso
es solo la última advertencia de que las
empresas tecnológicas podrían estar
creando un monstruo que no controlar en
marzo después de que opinais lanzar el
último modelo su chatbot más de mil
personas del sector tecnológico entre
ellas el multimillonario elon musk y el
cofundador de Apple Steve wosniak
firmaron una carta pidiendo una
moratoria en el desarrollo de la
Inteligencia artificial hington también
pidió a los desarrolladores que hicieran
una pausa el jefe científico de Google
respondió a sus entrevistas en un
comunicado seguimos comprometidos con un
enfoque responsable de la Inteligencia
artificial aprendemos continuamente para
comprender los riesgos emergentes al
tiempo que innovamos con audacia el
propio Hilton afirmó que Google ha
actuado hasta ahora como un
administradora adecuado de la tecnología
pero que está sufriendo una presión cada
vez mayor por parte de la competencia
advierte que los gigantes tecnológicos
están atrapados en una carrera que
requerirá una regulación mundial para
frenarla hasta aquí este informativo
llegan con más noticias en France 24
[Música]